we now have approximately 2% of the
historical natural population of African
penguins that's the population that was
recorded in late 1800s
they've been several threats to penguins
egg collection people collect the tectum
likes to eat and more recently the major
threats have been habitat encroachment
people and then also the major depletion
of fish in the sea and so a lack of new
homes we do have a major problem with
there not being an efficiency and that
affects the whole life cycle of the
Penguins say they don't find enough fish
and then they can't breathe our major
concern is still overfishing and
depleted fish stocks and it's the
sardines and anchovies the Penguins
naturally eat which are also heavily
fished by people
I'm the finical bit my job entails
looking off to the health and the
welfare of a bird I evaluate them and we
make diagnosis and treatment plans and
then I would see their people until
they're released again sometimes we find
some tea birds and they just need to be
fed or treated
superficially and healthy enough and I
can go back into the wild and sometimes
that can be here for almost up to a year
if they aren't waterproof enough then we
can't release them into the wild because
they need some 80% of the time and if
they're not what routine they can get
very cold neck and get hypothermia which
you can get to they do most of our
penguins that come in as chicks which
have been abandoned by their parents due
to molting and so to help bolster the
natural pigment population we take those
in but the ones that I have to deal with
usually have wounds wounds or no body
weight the wounds can be caused by by
predators the pollution or boats
the great thing about penguins is
they're just really tough so they can
overcome broken bones and huge wounds
and bites by sharks and very
successfully heal and grow and be able
to release threatens the world where
they they'll still live a proper life
you